you get given this right and your eyes
to show that all of the coefficient
adults is that okay which is fine
95% of you guys attempted this the way
you would expect it which is checks + y
- 5 is a binomial it's an equation I am
good extended by diversity just expanded
it you have a look at the knowledge and
sure enough there are contributors 23
minor note it's a little embarrassing
when you come up with numbers that don't
add up to 243 and you're like oh but if
they're supposed to up the 243 so you
just budget don't do that we're looking
for the way that you've got the number
there there is actually a much easier
way of completely alternate way of Jesus
and the further you go to the extension
would cost the more that this will occur
so look at your solution in a minute
because it might be totally fine if what
you're after is the coefficients okay
for example how to think about this guy
the very first term will be this do you
agree I mean I could write a lose but
that's fine
so in other way what's the number you
want out of this but the 32 is the
important part okay but a really quick
way to get to that is to notice that one
way of saying what are the coefficients
equal to use what is it equal to what
the whole thing equals to if I don't
worry about it
X's and Y's right now when I say don't
worry about the excellent wise just make
them tribute okay there's a value for x
and y that you can choose that makes
them contribute nothing to the
coefficients right in X well one it's
excellent one you will just get out the
32 right that's the part that you want
okay I in the same way if you make y
equal 1 the last term is going to be
wider than 5 right well the value that
you're after this case is 1 so again if
you make y equal 1 then you will get out
just the one that you're after
does that make sense so in fact a nice
completely unrelated semi unrelated way
is just say X&Y let them be one what
happens to this thing reason which is
200 points straight okay that's a sweet
way to get into the box